[Music]
now sashay
away and we love you so much yeah i love
you you should be so proud of yourself
of course things didn't turn out
probably as you would hoped um but what
are some of the emotions you're feeling
today after last night's elimination you
know it's definitely a lot of mixed
emotions i'm definitely feeling
obviously sad angry
mad
sad mad angry i'm so proud of myself
every day i i have to pinch myself and
be like i actually do that so honored to
have had this opportunity and been able
to you know share my art and my drag
with canada listen there are some iconic
drag performers who are like the first
ones out like shangela comes to mind uh
miss vanjie comes to mind do you feel
like you're kind of part of a special
club now what they call it the pork chop
lounge you know like
i i feel like i'm in great company
honestly like
the first out girls there's some really
there's some really iconic ones you
mentioned in your entrance that you are
socially anxious my name is beth i'm
campy glamorous and socially anxious
would you say the experience of being in
this reality
competition series was a lot harder than
you had ever imagined i wouldn't want to
say it was harder it was just completely
different than what i expected to have
like it to be like
[Music]
a lot of people
last night were very put off by eve
6000's reaction to being safe
it was a lot of emotion for being safe
we will say that so what was your
reaction to how eve handled being safe
i mean i totally understand where she
was coming from definitely in that
moment i was just like okay girl like
i'm about to listen for my life like
stop trying to take my moment here this
may be my last time to shine stop making
it about you there's a lot of vancouver
drag performers this season the brat
pack of course who were three drive
performers you kind of mentioned you
looked up to when you first moved to the
big city do you think that was
intimidating in any ways having the brat
pack there or would you say it was
comforting definitely a mixture of both
beth can be a little bit hard on herself
sometimes knowing her from a competition
sense previously i have seen that so i'm
hoping that she can push through and
trust herself because what she does is
amazing i know kendall probably the best
out of the three of them and you know
when she was there it was really
exciting to you know have someone who i
really admire as a performer and really
admire as a person and an activist as
well obviously they're intimidating
they're amazing amazing performers
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos